[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in peter king football
morning in america columnist and uh also
contributes to nbc sports as well peter
good morning how are you
hey dan everything's going great how
about you oh good if i told you a week
ago that mac jones would be the starter
in new england or that cam newton was
going to be released which one would
have surprised you the most cam newton
being released and it just says to me
that
hey bill belichick wants to make a clean
break and look dan for the last 12
months
everybody who has watched cam newton
play
has been trying to think of reasons why
he doesn't look like cam newton
and why he wasn't the cam newton of
you know five six years ago he's still
young relatively speaking in quarterback
age
and but the fact is
cam newton had not played well
and
you know i i remember uh covering bill
parcells
for four years in the 80s when i worked
for newsday and he's coaching the giants
with bill belichick on the staff
once a week bill parcells would have
this mantra fellas saying to guys in the
press because at that time there were no
women covering the team fellas i can
only go by what i see
and
bill belichick this summer
watched as mac jones maybe marginally
but certainly did outperform
uh cam newton in training camp so i
think he just felt like
i didn't see very much with cam newton
last year
and the rookie has outperformed him this
year
and the rookie certainly doesn't either
play or act like a rookie i'm going with
them so
uh i i i applaud bill belichick i i
really think that quarterbacks come in
different shapes and sizes and mental
acuity and obviously this guy who he has
he feels can can handle what brian
flores is going to throw at him in 10
days
what about uh cam's future as a starter
i mean
would you hire cam newton and put him in
a starting quarterback role right now i
wouldn't if you're the texans would you
well
you know you ask yourself here's the
question
if you're the houston texans
do you bring cam newton a tarnished cam
newton inn
who has not uh done anything in your
playbook
in the entire offseason and do you bring
them in and give them a crash course and
try to get them ready to play
jacksonville
uh in 10 days or to get them ready to
play at some point this year yeah maybe
you do
but
i just dan i watched cam newton play
last year i don't know what that was
really he's okay
but to me
the big question is would cam newton be
a backup for backup money
and maybe work himself back into
position to earn a starting job i think
it would take a lot of humility to do
that he might do it i don't i don't
really know cam newton so i can't tell
you what he might do but
i think it would take some humility for
him to go somewhere
right now
as a backup player so if i were him i'd
sit i'd sit out wait until somebody had
a desperate need for a quarterback had a
big injury and then i would sign with
that team yeah i can't see him doing
what jameis winston did in new orleans
where
you know you go in there and you're just
going to sit and be quiet and watch drew
brees uh you know i know there are other
landing spots you know would the
pittsburgh steelers work for cam newton
um
would the ravens work as a backup
quarterback a minnesota viking situation
i don't buy the dallas cowboys you know
bringing him in uh as a big personality
i just knowing cam
he he doesn't want i just don't think he
can
process being a backup quarterback i
just i don't i just don't see that
happening
i
i mean look football i think is so
different from the other sports you know
in baseball i
turned on the tv the other night and i
see the red sox are pitching brad
peacock
and you know so in in baseball
everybody gets recycled about six times
and in football
you know a backup quarterback can get
recycled josh mccown can
play for 15 years as a backup
quarterback which he did he made a lot
of money he had a little bit of glory
i'm sure he had a lot of fun
but you have to be willing to say i am
in service to the guy in front of me
and maybe cam newton can say that as i
say i don't know
but i certainly wouldn't say hey cam
you're our guy what has he done
recently to prove that
he should have a franchise put in his
hands
i know urban meyer came out and talked
about you know those that weren't
vaccinated that they he did factor that
in and uh who he was going to cut um i
was told this morning that uh
the nfl players association might be
looking into the titans and the colts
for doing the same thing
but i just don't know how you prove that
i don't know if bill belichick didn't
want to keep ken newton because he
wasn't vaccinated on top of not
performing that well
can the league can the players
association
fight this
do they you know is there any headway
that can be made here that guys got cut
because in part they're not vaccinated
i think you would have to prove that
the guy had equal ability to another
player and the only reason that he was
cut is because he was unvaccinated i
think if you can prove that and i think
that's going to be hard to prove
then you probably have a case i think
this is one of the dumbest rules i've
ever seen enacted in my 38 years
covering the nfl
who
wouldn't consider vaccine status
when understand this dan
an unvaccinated player tests positive
on a friday
he is missing his team's next two games
i mean
what if you're the miami dolphins
or jacksonville uh tampa
you were in a state where the virus is
on fire
and it's all you can do every day to
avoid any of your guys getting the virus
i
i don't i think you would be
irresponsible
to not consider
a player's vaccination status when
figuring out your final roster
particularly if you're a team in florida
but
it feels like urban meyer said what
others think and maybe that's what got
him in trouble i mean he did yeah but i
mean he's used to saying what he wants
to because he was in college and nobody
was really checking him on this you know
what i i was told this after urban said
what he said and that is that
there was not a single one of the final
cuts of the jaguars that it came down to
vaccination status
was uh you know did were they aware of
vaccination status of the players they
kept and the players they cut yes
and again dan i am not i'm not reporting
that vaccination status had nothing to
do with it because i don't know that but
what i do what i have heard
reliably is that it wasn't the driving
force in any of the roster decisions
they made but i think urban meyer was
simply saying
uh what every other coach in the league
every other general manager in the
league takes into account which is
we will
know and factor in a player's
vaccination status you know why because
it is irresponsible not to
the
desean watson situation to me
is
he's going to be a healthy scratch he's
eligible to play
hasn't been charged
and
it feels like
the texans are saying
we'll pay him 10 million dollars
for us to tank then he's not going to
play doesn't want to play we don't want
him to play we're going to wait until we
get a good offer
how do you make sense of this
i think they have gotten
a couple of good offers
but they haven't gotten the offer
recently
in my opinion
i think when the history book history
chapter is written on this story
if we ever find out exactly what
caroline offered way back before we knew
any of this stuff we'll say holy cow
they turned down that
and obviously in retrospect
uh i'm sure they wish they took that
whatever that exactly is
but uh i i think that um the reason why
he's not on the commissioner's exempt
list yet and why the nfl has really got
to think hard about this i think lindsey
jones wrote a good story about it at the
athletic
they have to think about whether they
want this sort of sort of damocles
hanging over their heads
and
if the texans tomorrow said our starting
quarterback is desean watson is the
league going to let that happen
that is going to be the test i don't
think the texans are going to say that
but
i do think that the league
should clarify his status before the
start of the year yeah i was wondering
um can they punish him
prior to this investigation being
completed
that's a good question i don't think
they want to set that precedent but i
also don't think they want to put a
quarterback on the field
with
22 cases
uh involving a possible sex crime in
each
um
they don't want to put that guy on the
field and i have a feeling right now
that the texans are doing the nfl office
a solid
by just keeping desean watson in limbo
he's peter king and his column must read
every monday morning football morning in
america the packers and saints relocate
to jacksonville why jacksonville
i was a little surprised it wasn't
dallas uh because that's where the
saints are
but
i think logistically
um the
uh the nfl thought that jacksonville was
the best
place for them
because of availability
and because
quite honestly
they absolutely didn't want to do
anything that would give the packers
any sort of home field advantage and as
strange as this sounds dan
i think it's a slight bit of a home
field advantage
for new orleans fans who can drive seven
hours to this game and it's going to be
outside so that is an advantage even
though new orleans plays inside they're
practicing in that you know 95 degree
heat index most days
and so i just think in terms of home
field advantage jacksonville seemed like
a better place
than dallas but again
i think that logistically there must
have been some issues also in dallas
that prevented the relocation of the
game there when do you make your super
bowl pick
monday and i haven't done it yet i
the one thing i do know is i just can't
pick kansas city tampa
i want to i think they're the two best
teams
but it never happens so
that's it did that happen with what
dallas and buffalo right
uh almost 30 years ago
i just i just
it's just so rare
uh and i'm not sure whether i'm going to
pick either one of them i i've got some
interesting candidates on the outside
that i'm considering okay but if i said
you could pick
kansas city or tampa to go to the super
bowl
which one would you take
i'd probably
take
uh i'd probably take kansas city
um
and that's an odd thing to say because i
do think that in many ways
tampa's road is slightly easier
i know this is crazy dan i just
i just think that covet is going to
impact
teams in these hot spot areas i just
don't know how
i i i it's just too it's too prevalent
and
it's just too hard
to put your players in bubble wrap for
the year maybe it'll maybe it'll have an
impact on kansas city players too
because in missouri there's obviously um
you know
scattered outbreaks as well so
i don't know but i think both of those
teams on paper right now are the best in
the afc and nfc
if you were going to bet whether the
patriots make the playoffs or not
definitely yes
definitely
definitely yes
i would bet that in fact
right now i am really on the precipice
to try to determine
which team
is better right now miami or new england
and i think dan
there has been this thought that okay
new england's got a lot of areas to
rebuild
you know i didn't watch a lot of
preseason football of the patriots
but i'll tell you that front seven is
damn good
and it's very deep
and they are going to give a lot of
quarterbacks a lot of problems you i
watched the the giants game the other
day
and they just they were they over
matched if that's such a word
uh the the giants offensive front now we
all know that the giants are in trouble
on the offensive front but
i'll tell you
new england toyed with them and
and and i you know i don't know i don't
put a lot in pre-season games but when
bill belichick plays the ones
he is asking them to play
at a regular season level
and i think their front seven could be
really really good
give me a good team that will disappoint
this
year you ask me the opposite i would say
the chargers
if you ask me a good team that will
disappoint
i might say miami because even though i
like miami and i like a lot of moves
they made
i right now as we sit here i just have
no idea how to was going to play
and you can have all of the good wishes
and good feelings going for you
but if your quarterback doesn't play
well
i you you're not going to be good
and you know i worry a little bit about
the vikings too i worry that the vikings
which have who have so many good
defensive players back for him
are really reliant on kirk cousins in a
huge huge way
and as i said at the start of this
conversation if an unvaccinated player
tests positive on friday he misses his
next two games
and
whether it's going to be a pickup of
sean mannion
or a very weak back-up quarterback
situation
led by kellen monde in minnesota
i would not be confident you can win
maybe you can win one game without kirk
cousins and i'm not saying that kirk
cousins is tom brady but i'm saying that
he's a lot better than anybody else they
have
thank you pete we look forward to
monday's column thanks for joining us
all the best dean thank you so much
peter king football morning and america
columnist and uh contributor to
nbcsports.com